in that september 2020 interview
vanessa bryant's mom sophia lane claimed
she had been kicked out of her home
by her daughter now things are getting
messier
sophia is suing vanessa and the kobe
bryant trust for financial support
claiming kobe promised to take care of
her for the rest of her life
before he and daughter gianna died in
january 2020.
in these court docs obtained by e.t
sophia claims she worked unpaid as a
long-time personal assistant and nanny
for the family
which includes kobe and vanessa's other
three daughters natalia
bianca and capri the docs also say quote
kobe bryant's promises did not see the
light of day as he is now deceased and
vanessa bryant took
each and every step she could to void
and cancel all of kobe bryant's promises
she's amazing i was there helping you
know
doing everything i possibly can to make
the process easier for my wife
and uh you know but ultimately you know
she did all the work i was just there
just trying to help out
now vanessa is responding claiming her
mom is trying to extort a financial
windfall from the family
in a statement to e.t she says quote i
have supported her for nearly 20 years
and she was never my or kobe's personal
assistant
nor was she a nanny she says her mom
watched her granddaughters from time to
time
like most grandparents do but adds quote
she now wants to back charge me 96
dollars per hour for supposedly working
12 hours a day
for 18 years for watching her
grandchildren
in reality she only occasionally babysat
my older girls when they were toddlers
vanessa also addresses her mom's
september interview
quote even after that betrayal i was
willing to provide my mother with
monthly support for the rest of her life
and that wasn't good enough she instead
contacted me through intermediaries and
demanded five million dollars
a house and a mercedes suv
vanessa goes on to call her mom's
lawsuit frivolous disgraceful
and unimaginably hurtful and says quote
my husband never promised my mother
anything and he would be
so disappointed in her behavior and lack
of empathy
vanessa is seemingly surrounded by a
great group of supportive friends
earlier this year her close pal lala
anthony praised her
i talked to her every single day and
just you know continue to
pray for her and stay positive for her
she
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and um
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing
the proud mom has also been sharing
special moments with her loved ones
and daughters to instagram
[Music]
nothing